so what are you going to do this year I
don't like making
um resolutions because I always fail at
them so we're doing like what are you
going to do better at what's like what
are you doing for yourself this year I
always make a ridiculous list of
resolutions most of which are totally
unobtainable and then it gets to yeah
like December and I'm like oh I didn't
do any of that but uh some are
achievable like one year I was like I
want to learn to make jam and oh I was
able to accomplish I made change I made
Champs was it good jam it was pretty
good to be honest I'd still buy it
instead of making it but anyway it's a
process yeah yeah I did it on a really
hot day too which I don't recommend do
it in winter anyways this year
it was on my list last year I didn't get
around to it but I really want to learn
the banjo I the best oh my God
I'm telling you literally my band they
all play like everything specifically
Jocko as well you play banjo as well
you're incredible
oh I'm I'm just when do I start honestly
tomorrow okay
I'm not kidding I've been looking for a
banjo teacher
teacher we're like we know a banjo
player and he's really good
um why banjo I'm just curious I I don't
know it just seems like a great
instrument I love the sound of it and I
also I know this is silly but like I
think it'd be really funny if I was ever
on a camping trip and I played like the
music from Deliverance just to freak
people out hiding a tree and do it but I
think what would freak them out if he
yelled squeal piggy squiggles yeah yeah
yeah yeah well I thought look if they
don't get that reference then there's a
few go-to lines and and hopefully
they'll pick up oh my God but yeah it
was a cool instrument and I wanna I
wanna learn I've been learning French
but I want to be fluent in French that
would be cool I've been learning Spanish
for decades it's like I it's unless you
practice it every day like my brain just
doesn't work like that it will it does
not sink it I can read it but speaking
that's the hardest thing do you find I
yes I can unders yeah especially like
with French it's like I'm pretty good at
reading it and then if I'm hearing it
and then as soon as someone asks me to
speak I'm like yeah and then you tense
up and you're like I've never heard this
language in my entire life before yep on
the flip side I just work my amazing
co-star Diego Calvert who's in Babylon
English is his second language which
Spanish is his first language he's from
Mexico City and some have done this
entire Journey with him and still don't
know I like my Spanish has not improved
at all he meanwhile like learned his
English perfectly could improvise entire
scenes in English I mean he was
remarkable it is remarkable people can
pick the pick it up so quickly yeah I
think it's beautiful so many people are
bilingual trilingual yeah especially in
the Europe I only speak Australian
English American I love that you said
Australia yeah that's different totally
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]